this is one of the best laptops in the
world Samsung's Galaxy book 3 Ultra
because not only does it have Intel's 13
gen processors the fastest chip we've
ever built but also Nvidia 40 series
graphics and today we are going to
compare everything from the design the
displays speakers and webcams all the
way to Performance both in benchmarks
and real world tasks along with a couple
new tests as far as price they are very
similar the Samsung is a hundred dollars
less expensive and it comes with a
terabyte of storage which is awesome
we're gonna test that out but you can
buy the MacBook right now for a hundred
dollars Less on Amazon links are down
below as far as the design and ports you
have the classic Mac look and the
Samsung also looks very classy and nice
minimalist design we have vents here on
the bottom I like the color but it is a
fingerprint magnet the MacBook keeps the
vents on the side so they're not as
easily blocked but the same Samsung has
some big speaker ports that should have
impressive speakers as far as weight the
Samsung is noticeably lighter even
though it is made out of metal and as
far as thickness they are almost
identical back to back but the Samsung
does have a more classy wedge shape as
far as ports I do like the Samsung still
gives you a USB type a port but I wish
the micro SD card slot was a full size
both of them have HDMI but the MacBook
has that nice magnetic Maxi charger and
you have three Thunderbolt ports instead
of two on the inside both of these do
have fingerprint scanners to log in but
I really wish that the ultra had my
favorite Windows feature which is
Windows hello but it doesn't one thing
it does have is a numpad on the sides
over here so it's so nice to enter
numbers having this where's the MacBook
just has these large speakers as far as
keyboards the Samsung does have
shallower keys but they do feel quite
nice with that said the macbook's magic
keyboard feels better and for track pads
of course the MacBook has the best
trackpad but I was really shocked at how
large this Samsung trackpad is it is
massive now it is still a diving board
design uh but it is nice and responsive
now above that we have the displays and
this Samsung has a Super AMOLED display
that is very impressive but before we
compare them if you're a Mac or Windows
user who does any sort of work with
documents spreadsheets or slideshows on
your Mac or Windows computer our sponsor
software keep is giving our viewers 25
off on genuine Microsoft software like a
one-time purchase of Microsoft Office
for Mac or Windows which includes word
XL and PowerPoint now there are so many
fishy websites out there that could scam
you but soft4keep is a Microsoft
certified partner who sells only 100
genuine Microsoft software so you don't
have to worry which resulted in software
keep earning over 100 thousand five star
reviews they also have great prices on
other software including the most
popular antivirus software out there and
their customer service is phenomenal
with 24 7 365 customer support where you
will talk to a real person instead of a
robot so if you have any questions
they'll be glad to help so buy Microsoft
Office for Mac windows or anything else
that you need today and save 25 off
their already great prices by using the
link in the description and the coupon
code
mtyt25 now both of these are 16 inch
displays and the Samsung has a 2880 by
1800 resolution the same as the older
MacBooks now this new 16-inch has a high
resolution but can I tell with my eyes
no both of them look super sharp and
what's even cooler is the fact that
they're using a 16 by 10 and they have a
120 hertz refresh rate so everything is
super smooth it could also dynamically
switch between 60 and 1 120 hertz of
course with the MacBook we have Pro
motion so it could do up to 120 hertz
but it can drop down all the way to 24
matching your content and that saves
more battery now since I mentioned
battery the MacBook has a 100 watt hour
battery the maximum amount you can have
on an airplane compared to the Samsung's
77 watt hour so it's definitely less
there as well and they give you 100 watt
charging brick which is nice but the
MacBook has a 140 watt so it does charge
super fast now as usual the battery life
claims are very high in Windows laptops
but in terms of real world usage the
MacBook does beat it out looking at
these displays I am impressed with the
Samsung oftentimes with OLED screens the
black should be pure black but because
of the anti-reflectivity they look great
but this one does look nice and dark now
it does have more Reflections than the
Macbook so that is noticeable in a room
like this I think this is the best OLED
screen I've seen on a laptop and as far
as viewing angles it is better than the
macbook's mini LED display but in terms
of Maximum brightness if you're looking
straight on the MacBook does get
brighter at 500 nits now as far as HDR
the MacBook can actually get up to 1600
nits compared to around 500 on the OLED
now this video right here only goes up
to a thousand but you guys can see the
difference not only in brightness but
also in the detail and the highlights
which is also visible in these dark
shots here where we have a lot of fine
detail and brightness compared to
something that looks blown out now mini
LED can have blooming issues which does
get annoying but overall the experience
is a lot better and it's going to take a
long time before OLED can get this
bright with dual layer technology now
what about the speakers in the webcam
Samsung advertised they're really nice
quad powerful speakers of course the
MacBook has six speakers so let's go
ahead and take a listen
[Music]
forgive me
all right guys you heard that for
yourselves no matter how you're
advertising the truth comes out well I
know some people say you guys don't like
Samsung we gave great reviews to the s23
Smoke die from 14. a lot of the products
are good but here you guys heard the
MacBook has so much more bass it's
louder a lot more rich and it makes for
a great movie watching experience but
what about the webcams Samsung also
advertised their really nice webcams so
let's take a look this is the 16-inch
MacBook Pro's 1080p webcam and studio
quality microphones quality and this is
the galaxy book Ultras wide 1080p webcam
quality and it also has dual
front-facing microphones let me know
which one looked better and sounded
better down in the comment section below
getting into performance the Samsung
comes with one terabyte of SSD compared
to 512 so how fast is it let's go ahead
and run this test all right we have our
results and the Samsung is way faster
than the MacBooks I thought maybe they
could have been cheaper ssds because it
could be a terabyte but no now with the
MacBook you can actually get speeds that
are faster than Samsung but you have to
spend a lot of money to upgrade to one
terabyte now with that one thing that
I've never tested before is Samsung's
Quick Share which is the same thing as
airdrop for iPhone so I'm gonna see how
well does this actually work click on
the s23 ultra I'm going to start a timer
here this is a 577 megabyte file that
took 27 seconds to transfer it was very
easy to do so I'm actually impressed it
works well wow 28 seconds for the iPhone
using the latest MacBook latest iPhone
and same thing with the Samsung so
airdrop is no longer exclusive great job
Samsung and now let's compare the CPU
performance using geekbench the Samsung
has a 13 700 H 14 core 20 thread
processor up to 4.8 gigahertz compared
to 12 cores that goes up to 3.5
geekbench 6 is way more realistic for
modern loads so let's see what we get
this test takes way longer with
geekbench 6 but it's a lot more
realistic for modern loads alright we
have our Scores And as far as single
core the MacBook is only seven percent
faster but in multi-core score here we
have 10 400 compared to fourteen
thousand that's a difference of 35 in
favor of the M2 Pro chip that has a
lower clock frequency and less cores but
you guys may have noticed we're running
on battery power and so far the Samsung
has been doing pretty good so let's go
ahead and plug in the power all right
there we go the numbers went up from 10
000 to 12 500 that's 21 faster if you
plug it in and yes I did have it set to
best performance on battery but that 12
500 is still not enough to compete with
the macbook's 14 000 being 12 faster and
all on battery performance but what
about Graphics we have 19 Graphics cores
with the M2 Pro compared to the RTX 4050
studio version which is supposed to be
optimized for compute tasks like this
and it looks like the MacBook one we
have 81 700 compared to sixty nine
thousand three hundred the difference of
close to 20 percent but of course the
Windows laptop is plugged in so if we go
ahead and unplug that and then run it
again we see 47
000 so it's not twice as powerful in the
MacBook uh but getting closer to there
so yes if you want the best performance
on the Samsung both CPU and Graphics
unfortunately you have to have it
plugged in now what about web-based apps
for example here we have figma for web
design using a project that our partner
500 designs made for us they're one of
the best Design Studios in La so here we
have a high res website and I'm just
going to go ahead and zoom in right here
see how responsive things are so wow
that uh was very quick to go ahead and
refresh everything give us the high
resolution files let's try here
um couple seconds lagging a little bit
bam kicked in so overall nice and smooth
this 13 gen does a great job let's test
out the MacBook
zoom in
started refreshing bam also very fast
maybe slightly faster or maybe the same
I would say it's about on par and now I
selected 12 high resolution layers and
we are going to export this web page and
the MacBook took one minute and 35
seconds quite a bit faster and doing it
on battery so that's pretty impressive
now people say why do you guys do so
many different tests well we want to see
the whole picture not just one Benchmark
people say this the best one is laptop
it is very nice but it is definitely
hard to compete with the Mac especially
when it comes to Performance now Windows
laptops are great for gaming so I'm
going to run 3D Marks Wildlife extreme
unlimited to make it completely Fair
regardless of resolution the results
show as legendary on the Samsung but the
MacBook actually has a higher score
looking at 77.8 FPS compared to 67.3 so
roughly 15 16 better frame rate so I
guess is also legendary now of course
there are way more games for Windows
they're well optimized we actually made
a dedicated gaming video on these new
MacBooks so you guys can check that out
both running crossover for Windows games
and dedicated ones that are optimized
like the new Resident Evil now one area
Nvidia Graphics are amazing is for 3D
rendering using blender especially when
you enable support for Ray tracing
course doing the rendering so here we
have the BMW test which is probably the
most popular one and let's go ahead and
render it we have Ray tracing compared
to metal and look at that difference we
have 40 seconds for the MacBook compared
to 14 seconds yes more than twice as
fast with the RTX graphics card on the
Samsung this is where it destroys the
MacBook but what about for other
creative tasks for example I have
Photoshop Lightroom classic opened up
right here with 50 high resolution
edited images I went in I made sure to
enable full Graphics acceleration for
export on the Windows laptop as well
flipping through files where they have
the same settings I have to render each
time the results are pretty much the
same after that first photo maybe
slightly slower on the Windows Samsung
laptop even though we have that faster
SSD and now let's go ahead and Export
these 50 images and of course I have the
Windows laptop plugged in for the best
performance now as this runs one of the
things I have to mention is the fan
noise and the temperatures on the
MacBook the fans are still off and
they've been silent the whole time which
is crazy with the M2 Pro there is the
fans are designed for overhead for the
higher end Graphics while this one I can
clearly hear the fans even when running
geekbench on the Windows laptop we are
reaching actually almost five gigahertz
4.998 that's five gigahertz compared to
3 0.3 on the MacBook and we are using a
lot more power I see 55 it's going all
over the place probably trying to keep
itself cool compared to using about 37
or so looks like each image gets
rendered and it kind of slows down now
let's take a look at Thermals here we
have 38 degrees Celsius on the Windows
laptop you guys see that hot spot and on
the Mac 31 32
definitely cooler in a smaller hot spot
and the results are in the Windows
laptop took a minute and 32 seconds
definitely really nice and quick but the
MacBook took 58 seconds to do that quite
a bit faster and of course on batteries
so for photo editing the processing
power the unified memory architecture is
very efficient now what about video
editing I have DaVinci Resolve 18 Studio
opened which is extremely well optimized
for both and this is a 4K hf265 graded
projects with Luts film grain both are
playing it back perfectly fine with no
issues our MacBooks only using about 13
of the graphics meaning it has a ton of
overhead for more effects multi-cam
footage now the windows is using about
36 of that Nvidia graphics card so it
needs more of that performance to do
this and now let's go ahead and Export
this five minute project and let's see
how they do the Nvidia card is doing not
too bad but the Mac is running faster
the MacBook took a minute 20 seconds
compared to a minute and 44. now both
these are very fast I have to say I'm
very impressed with the Samsung and the
Nvidia graphics card the previous
generation similar one uh the 3050 TI
that would have taken way longer so this
is great now of course it is plugged in
most likely you would be rendering with
the plugged in with the Mac I typically
don't because the performance stays the
same but let's try it out just to see
the difference that we get and that took
two minutes and 40 seconds not that much
longer yes it is longer that does kind
of suck but before sometimes you'd go
from three minutes to 12 that would be
very terrible so with all of that said
um how these compare how does the best
Windows laptop I've seen a lot of people
say this uh in 2023 very well-rounded
compared to the MacBook well in certain
cases it beats it out but in a lot of
instances for a similar price point with
the discounts available now you do get a
better product that will hold its value
better you'll have better battery life
it will perform the same on battery uh
overall I do think it's the better buy
as long as you don't need Windows but
you guys let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below what other
kind of videos would you guys like to
see if you want to hear you guys opinion
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right there for example the Mt Max
compared to an RTX 4090 very crazy and
we'll see you in the next one
[Music]